here is a challenging admissions  question how many triangles can be  formed by 20 points 12 of which lie on  one line and another eight on another  parallel line it is not stated but it is  assumed the points must be the vertices  of the triangle  obviously there will be too many cases  to manually count all of the triangle so  let's systematically count it we know  that three points on the same line will  not form a triangle so we need two  points from one line and one point from  another so this is either 12 choose two  multiplied by eight choose one or twelve  choose one multiplied by 8 choose two so  this will be 12 times 11 over 2  multiplied by eight plus twelve  multiplied by eight multiplied by 7 over  2. this simplifies to be  864 and that's the answer